bonsoir monsieur girard bonsoir monsieur
gérard est ce que vous auriez pu
aujourd'hui décidé d'en faire plus pour
la relance économique
ou c'est trop important de réduire le
déficit et de revenir au déficit zéro
c'est à dire que ce qui est le plus
important dans l'immédiat c'est la
sécurité sanitaire et c'est pour ça que
depuis début de crise nous avons ajouté
5 milliards de dollars pour le personnel
l'équipement lilith est dépistage et il
n'y a pas de relance économique sans la
sécurité à l'eau chantal la deuxième
banque
on le disait un pantin ctions fait un
saint mais quand on parle de relance
parce que là on évoque dans cette mise à
jour la relance de l'économie
la relance verte on parle d'à peu près
un milliard cinq cent millions plus du
soutien aux gens pour un total d'un
milliard 800 millions
est ce que c'est vraiment assez pour
aider l'économie pour stimuler
l'économie et a dit que en tout ce que
nous faisons c'est 13 milliards depuis
le mois de mars
alors on a les circonstances actuelles
dans la crise on n'attend pas la mise à
jour budgétaire pour annoncer les
annonces alors depuis le portrait en
juin il ya eu 4 milliards d'années
et là on en rajoute 1.8 milliard ici à
des besoins supplémentaires ici et le
budget on va faire d'autres choses
quitte à avoir un déficit de caisse 17
20 milliards mais on a une provision
dans le déficit de 15 milliards qui est
prévu nous avons une provision pour
éventualités de 4 milliards alors c'est
possible de l'utiliser
effectivement vous avez une provision de
4 milliards quand je prends votre 15
milliards et que j'enlève la provision
chat rose et quand j'enlève le fonds des
générations chez autour de 8
et l'année prochaine vous prévoyez un
déficit de 8 milliards
si j'enlève la provision de 3 milliards
et le fonds des générations de 3
milliards il semble qu'on se rapproche
pratiquement de l'équilibré budgétaire
dans les faits dès l'an prochain
comment ça s'explique
c'est important les contributions au
fonds des générations et puis un débat
est-ce qu'on doit garder le surplus
comptable le surplus après les
contributions au fonds des générations
puis on aura ces discussions l'homme et
nous nous disons que les contributions
au fonds des générations sont
extrêmement importante parce que en plus
du déficit qui est l'écart entre les
revenus les dépenses courantes
nous faisons aussi des investissements
en infrastructures c'est à dire que la
dette augmente plus vite que simplement
la croissance des sites d'où
l'importance des contributions au fonds
des générations
ok mais j'insiste quand même sur la
provision qui est importante qui est
nécessaire pour un ministre des finances
comme vous le fonds des générations ce
sont des milliards supplémentaires parce
qu'en même temps vous voulez revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire puis vous dites
il faut contrôler les dépenses alors
contrôler les dépenses à 3 3 et demi
pour cent sachant que la santé a besoin
de 4 à 6% par année là est ce qu'on s'en
va vers un chemin de rigueur budgétaire
on s'en va vers une des niveaux de
dépenses qui est responsable c'est à
dire que comme les familles les
entreprises si on a 4 % de croissance de
revenus il est raisonnable devons 3 ou
trois et demi de croissance de dépenses
et ça c'est à long terme et à chaque
année il peut avons des divergences
entre les postes budgétaires mais nous
nous sommes engagés à maintenir les
coûts du système en santé et il ya
certainement des endroits on peut faire
des gains d'efficience
mais ça ça ça viendra après la crise
parce que l'on est en plus un vague et
on nous achetons 5 milliards
supplémentaires
vous nous préparer mentalement quand
même à ce trajet vers le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
rigueur austérité contrôle serré des
dépenses parce que c'est des bons mots
austérité c'est la période qui a été
caractérisée par un niveau de croissance
de dépenses de 1 %
ça c'est ce qu'a offert le précédent que
dans les deux premières années de leur
mandat et c'est ça qui a amené
l'introduction de ce terme
ensuite il y aurait eu il ya eu une
période la dernière année expressionart
fait les deux dernières années du
précédent gouvernement la dernière année
est celle où nous étions là les deux et
ça c'était 5% de croissance de dépenses
maintenant pour revenir à une
trajectoire instable
il faudra que les revenus croissent plus
vite que les dépenses donc 4% de
croissance de revenu toi toi et me sens
des départs jusqu'à est-ce que ses
revenus vont augmenter avec les
transferts fédéraux où on augmente quand
même si on n'a pas les transferts
fédéraux supplémentaires que vous
souhaitez en santé à dire que les
transferts fédéraux c'est une demande
historique des premiers ministres
provinciaux des territoires le fédéral
contribue 22 % des coûts totaux de la
santé 1 au canada et c'est le poste le
plus de poste budgétaire le plus
important
toutes les provinces alors il ya un
vieillissement de la population et les
nouveaux médicaments les nouvelles
technologies les besoins personnels
alors on a des défis en santé et nous
demandons au gouvernement fédéral
d'augmenter sa contribution
un seuil en demande d'un pour une
contribution 35% les négociations ne
sont pas morts et si c'est pas le cas si
a pas de traces heures supplémentaires
on fait quoi pour être un équilibre et
je pense d'une part je pense qu'il y
aura une augmentation des transferts
parce que les besoins sont là c'est pas
c'est pas les laissez pas la question
budgétaire qui fait qu'il est important
que le gouvernement fédéral augmente ses
transferts en santé c'est les besoins
si les citoyens du canada dans notre
coeur du québec qui ont si besoin et nos
ressentis la contribution du fédéral et
seulement 22 %
allez vous introduire une nouvelle loi
sur la dette
parce que là on devait atteindre 45%
d'une dette de 45% du pib en 2026 on
l'avait pas mal atteint avant la crise
on est à 50 faudrait revenir à 45 en
2026 et tout un trajet là est ce que
vous allez déposer un projet de loi pour
changer la doua la loi sur la cible de
la dette sont on va clarifier tout cela
au budget mais c'est certain que nous
l'avons dit en toute transparence les
cibles de la loi sur la gestion de la
dette et le fonds des générations
on est extrêmement douce et la peine
alors c'est plus probable nous puissions
respecter les cibles de cette loi la loi
sur laquelle nous concentrons nous
permet de la loi sur l'équilibré terre
nous demandent de revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire dans cinq ans mais nous
commençons à compter de l'an prochain
donc c'est sur six ans que nous pourrons
atteindre l'équilibré du temps donc
n'équilibre d'une part il ya la loi sur
l'équilibré budgétaire mais la loi sur
la dette
vous les voulez changer et demander si
nous ne pouvons atteindre les cimes
pardon j'ai raté ce que vous avez dit
jeudi que nous devrons amender la loi
sur le fonds des générations et la
gestion de la dette si c'est clair que
nous n'atteindrons pas les cibles en
2025 2026 ok très bien on va vous suivre
merci aussi gérard merci beaucoup